luke and nate here with the outdoor boys
youtube channel and we're here in the
white mountains of new hampshire
and it is a balmy 18 degrees fahrenheit
and we are going to do some serious
hiking and winter camping you ready nate
yeah all right let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
yeah i would make a good camp spot too
wouldn't it
oh that's cool
[Music]
the guys
what do you think nathan is this cool
oh we need to find a little cave like
that but one without water going through
[Music]
it
it's been fun but it's time to leave the
trail behind
[Music]
i mean this isn't a bad spot we can
clear away the snow and put the tarp
it'd be small but uh
that's not a bad spot to consider we'll
look around a little bit if we don't
find something better
we can come back to that the snow's not
too deep but it's really good we got our
gators on
even a little bit of snow down your
boots will melt and get your feet
soaking wet and frozen
oh this is birch bark and it's really
good fire starter
oh i see a big rock we could build a
shelter up against this rock
we'd have water nearby yeah look at that
that's pretty cozy yeah it wouldn't take
much to build a nice spot
oh lots of dead wood around that's good
hi daddy hi bud do we camp here
all right
we gotta kind of test the spot out make
sure it's comfortable
oh it's a little lumpy i'm not gonna lie
but it's better than most that okay all
right
all right
daddy
all right
well now i've got to make a hot tent
using only this tarp so we'll see how
that goes
[Music]
that'll keep the chimney from melting
the tarp right there
well it's pretty cozy in here this this
is going to work out pretty well i
i need to do a few things to secure this
tarp get a little bit more out of my way
i need to shove my bag down there to
plug up that hole
but i am worried that if i fire up that
stove it's going to start melting the
ice
and snow all on this wall i don't want
it dripping
down onto me so i think i might fire
that up first
and see if the water runs down the rock
or if it
drips we're gonna need to get a lot of
firewood luckily there's a lot of dead
wood around
that'll do
[Music]
[Music]
good
[Music]
[Music]
well it's getting dark quickly and the
sun's about to set and i have spent the
last three hours cutting firewood and i
think i have plenty uh my brain's still
in alaska mode where
the sun sets at 3 30 p.m and comes up at
10 30 a.m
so you need a ton of firewood to make it
through the night here in new england
it's not that bad
so i probably have way more firewood
than i need but nathan's been sleeping
and taking a little bit of a nap which
makes me happy here i'm gonna get the
the tent all warm and get some food made
and i'm gonna wake him up
all right i've got a cotton ball and i
put some petroleum jelly on it
and uh we're gonna light this sucker on
fire
and uh it light
very well
chimney seems to be working good tarp
looks like it's in good shape
excellent
this water's so clean i doubt there's
anything wrong with it
but we're gonna boil it anyways
my drinking bottles i'm going to keep
them
right here near the stove so they don't
freeze tonight
say nathan nathan buddy nathan do you
want cup of noodles
yeah hey buddy you have a good nap
all right here we go
let's grab it with the handle it's it's
hot just
whatever you do you cannot spill it in
your bed
that tastes good bud good
my wood hasn't been lighting as good as
i'd hoped because it's all
very cold and a little bit wet so i'm
putting it up here and letting it dry
out
once i need some wood and shove it in it
lights a lot better
yeah chicken teriyaki
that that tastes good
yeah be real careful oh that's good hot
chocolate
yep it's right now so you're still
hungry
i have a snack bag
for just such an issue now we have some
halloween candy
we have giant marshmallows strawberry
and vanilla
well so far i've been lucky and there's
been no dripping on me there's a few
places where water is running down the
rock
but it's not dripping on me so i think
it's safe to pull out my sleeping bag
my feet get really cold in my bag so
i've got these down
booties and they are really really good
at keeping my feet warm
we got a bunch of these adhesive hand
warmers i don't think nathan needs them
because he's got a great sleeping bag
mine's a little light for this weather
so
i am going to load up on hand warmers
they say these things last 12 hours but
i've had them last much longer
i've had boys wear them for 24 hours and
they're still really warm
oh that feels nice
well it's only about seven o'clock and
nathan had a pretty long nap
so i promised him we'd watch some tv
shows on my phone and
we're just gonna snuggle up all warm in
our sleeping bags and
hang out together for a little bit i'm
gonna keep this fire going and
we'll see it's supposed to get really
cold tonight
it was a high in the 20s today and the
low is
probably going to be in the single
digits
got a little bit of snow last night
good to see smoke coming out of that
thing oh
i really should have brought a pee
bottle i hate getting out to go to the
bathroom
oh excuse me all right it's breakfast
time
we got biscuits and gravy freeze-dried
[Applause]
hey nathan you sleep well yeah good
all right we've got some breakfast
marshmallows
what do you think david is that a
perfect marshmallow yep
there you go breakfast marshmallows
well we've done a lot of winter camping
with these two sleeping bags and
i gotta tell you i really like nathan's
feathered friends
makes this it's the negative 25 plover
it's the women's bag
and i just had them shorten it so that
it fits nathan
and it has just been so awesome man he
doesn't need hand warmers he just does
when it's zero degrees out he is so
toasty this is a true negative 25 bag
and it's got a waterproof shell
this north face inferno i'm not quite as
happy with
it's a really comfortable bag and it
moves with you really well and i like
the zippers up the chest instead of the
side makes a lot easier to get in and
out of
but this is not a negative 20 bag at
best it's a zero degree bag and
the way it's built the down shifts
around a lot when you stuff it in the
stuff sack
like right here i've got no insulation i
mean this is just
fabric there is no feathers here then
right here i've got a ton of feathers
and so you wake up all night with like
weird patches of your body really cold
like you know
right in your lower back or your butt
your thighs so i like
a lot of things about this north face
inferno but it's just not that warm i
think i'm gonna go
order one of these for me when we get
home do you like it nathan
i love it i love it i love i love it so
much
you ready to get out of your sleeping
bag and get dressed
[Laughter]
well i'm not in love with the idea of
getting out of my sleeping bag
i am excited for the hike back though
we're not just gonna backtrack the way
we came we're gonna go a different route
and uh we're gonna hike past the gorge
and some waterfalls and see some pretty
cool scenery so
i'm looking forward to that but first i
need to get up and get packed
oh oh no i stacked my boots up on my
sleeping bag last night
look what happened oh
oh i gotta go out there without shoes
and go get them and dry them off
gonna use my clown shoes
that looks cold
i like that you can go out in the snow
with these booties the bottom's
waterproof and there's no tread so it
doesn't track snow back into the tent
uh it's taken down the tarp and the tarp
fell onto the stove for just a second
and burned a hole right in it
[Music]
oh this was a fun campsite this turned
out a lot better than i expected
but uh we got a really fun return hike
we're gonna go
past some waterfalls and see some other
stuff i'm excited you ready nate
yeah let's do it i'll follow you
i swear that backpack's bigger than you
are nathan well right now me and my
whole family are spending a little over
a week
in maine we've rented a house there and
we're doing little side trips and
camping trips and
all sorts of fun things and we're doing
a whole video about that trip
if you guys want to see that video i'll
put a link in the video description to
that
you ready to go downhill nate
we're gonna
i killed david are you okay
you're still gonna go ahead and run
downhill yeah even though you've crashed
twice aren't you
we don't learn our lessons oh
we don't learn our lesson
at least i didn't do that one
oh careful you don't tear your pants
whoa
look at that look at that that's cool
yeah we gotta hike all the way around
yeah look at this then check out these
beams they're hand hewed
these are cut with an axe oh man that's
cool
cool yeah there's so many awesome hikes
that get kind of ruined
because they're too popular but you come
in the winter time like this
oh you get it all to yourself it's just
so nice
we don't learn our lesson do we we're
close to the end
i hope you guys enjoyed watching this
video as much as we enjoyed filming it
if you want to see more camping survival
hiking
that sort of video then check out our
camping adventure playlist i'll put a
link
down below in the video description and
don't forget to click subscribe we put
out new videos
every saturday morning thanks for
watching
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos
every saturday morning hit that bell
button you'll get notifications
thanks for watching